the North remembers we know no king but
the King in the north whose name is
stark I don't care if he's a busted that
starts blood runs through his veins
he's my king from this day until his
last day what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
Season eight prediction video today I
want to do something a little bit
different in this video I want to give
my own predictions for how I see the
first episode playing out so in today's
video I want to go over some of my own
ideas and predictions for the first
episode in the final season I could be
wrong or I could be right about some of
these things either way I would like for
you to call my down below and let me
know what you think and also let me know
what you think will happen in the first
episode you also have to remember each
episode might be around 90 minutes long
so a lot could still happen this season
even with only 6 episodes left and just
to keep in mind these are all my own
opinions I do not claim any of this to
be fact and also keep in mind that I am
NOT a writer so if the way I structure
this sounds like crap just show me some
mercy but I have a few general ideas of
how I think things are gonna play out
when the new season begins when season 8
episode 1 begins there are a few
different ways I think they may start
the season episode 1 might begin at
Winterfell with Bryan Stark the last
time we saw bran stark he was at the
weirwood tree and the godswood and he
had sent out a murder of crows to go and
keep an eye on the wall because he most
likely sent something was about to
happen and of course something did
happen the night king attacked the wall
with Vissarion and brought it down and
now his entire army is marching south so
the first episode may begin with bran
snapping out of his warding and
realizing what the hell he just saw
happened
bran stark will then let everyone at
Winterfell know that
eastwatch-by-the-sea was destroyed in
the night king is heading their way
then I think either brain or Sansa will
send out as many Ravens as possible to
let everyone know that the Great War is
officially here they will need all of
their banners to prepare for war and I
think this would be a really cool way to
start off this season but the first
scene could also be at the wall they
have done something like this before in
the past they end one episode at a
specific location and then the next
episode begins at that
location so they could begin this season
this way by basically showing the
aftermath at eastwatch-by-the-sea we
should see the dust starting to settle
and hopefully we could get a scene of
torment and beric looking at the now
destroyed wall wondering what the hell
they can do
I don't think torment and barek are
gonna be able to climb down the wall at
Eastwatch because the steps that were
built into the side of the wall were
destroyed so unless they have some
climbing gear stashed up there they're
gonna have to walk along the top of the
wall until they find a new place to get
to the ground there are some abandoned
castles all along the entire wall so
they could potentially climb down at the
next Castle but that all depends on how
long it's been out of commission because
it may not be safe enough to get down
there and if that's the case then
they're gonna have to walk along the top
of the wall until they make it to Castle
black and that's where they could ride
the elevator down and that's assuming
that night king doesn't stop there next
and destroy it but I don't think he will
I think the night king is heading south
to much bigger targets now if for some
reason they don't begin the season at
either of these two locations and I
think the next safest bet would be at
white Harbor
I think this would also be a good place
to start the season because this is
where Jon and Daenerys are gonna lay in
first and make their way to winter foul
but this is also where the timeline gets
a little bit tricky because the timeline
jumps around so much in the pace of the
show has picked up tremendously with the
last season so when Jon and Daenerys
arrive at white Harbor the word might
already be out that the wall has fell
because the last scene in the finale was
at the wall so they may speed things up
by having John and Daenerys find out
when they arrive at white Harbor and if
they don't find out immediately I still
think John is gonna find out the night
king is south of the wall before he gets
to Winterfell worst case scenario is he
will find out as he's heading north by
land but before I get into that I want
to talk about John and Daenerys his
first scene together I think there will
be a scene with John Dany and Tyrion or
John and Tyrion or even Dany and Tyrion
and the reason I say that is because I
think Tyrion is gonna want to express
his concerns about Jon and Daenerys his
newfound love for one another everyone
remembers the book Tyrion had on his
face when he knew Jon and Daenerys were
getting together so I think Tyrion may
pull one of them to the side and discuss
the potential problems this relationship
could cause Jon already knows how the
other northern Lords feel about the
Targaryen and it might not be a good
idea to show up in Winterfell after
being gone for several months
showing up holding hands within errors I
think Jonathan Eris are gonna keep their
relationship quiet at least for the
first episode John could try and show up
in Winterfell and tell everyone that he
is in love with Daenerys in hopes that
they will support their King and accept
an heiress immediately but that could
also backfire and cause a revolt and get
John killed so I think John will be
hesitant about telling anyone about him
and Daenerys and once he finds out he is
a Targaryen that's really gonna make
things awkward but it should make for a
really great in intense scene
anyways John Daenerys Tyrion and
everyone else they are with will reach
white Harbor in their first scene
together I'm not really sure if the news
about the night King is gonna have made
it to white Harbor yet unless this scene
takes place later into the episode but
considering Gendry could run to the wall
and get word to Daenerys in Dragonstone
all in the same episode then all bets
are off
news travels very fast these days but
let's move on to Cersei because there is
one scene that should have taken place
in season 7 that we did not see but I
think it's gonna take place in season 8
episode 1 if you read the plot League
for Season 7 then you should know that
it was about 99% accurate and as far as
I can remember the only thing we did not
see was Cersei having a miscarriage but
I think they're saving that to start off
the final season for her character now I
know some people have their own theories
about this because I heard some people
think she will give birth to a dwarf or
her baby will be the valonqar and she
will died during childbirth but I
disagree I do think she's still gonna
have a miscarriage and this is gonna be
the final act that sends Cersei into
complete and total madness after Jamie
left Cersei she may have still thought
to herself that at least she still has
this baby inside of her because we all
know that Cersei did truly love her kids
so being pregnant again gave her a new
comer of hope for the future but when
she loses this baby and she no longer
has Jamie around Circe's eyes will truly
glow like wildfire and her character
will take going out in a blaze of glory
to a whole new level
speaking of Jaime we should see him in
the first episode as well by the time we
see him again he should be many miles
away from King's Landing
as he makes his way north I am pretty
sure Jaime's gonna run into some people
along his way too and he is gonna be
very nervous about someone finding out
exactly who he is which is why he
covered up that golden hand as soon as
he got outside of King's Landing when we
see Jaime
it will probably be a scene of him being
stopped by some people as he heads north
and he's gonna be very nervous but Jamie
will most likely talk his way out of the
bad situation but I could also see Jamie
trying to blend in with some people so
he can make his way to Winterfell much
easier
pretty soon word is going to spread that
the night king has brought down the wall
and once the Starks send out word that
they all need all of their banners
everyone is gonna start to prepare for
the war so as Jamie heads north he might
cross paths with an army marching to
Winterfell and this is where Jamie could
try and blend in with the men heading
that way which could secure him a safe
way to get to Winterfell without being
killed
kind of like what ginjury did gangs we
hid in plain sight he stayed right in
King's Landing where he was one of the
most so Jamie could kind of do the same
thing by volunteering to go fight in the
north I won't be surprised if we see
Jamie get his hands or I should say hand
on a uniform that's usually worn by a
northern soldier and once he gets to
Winterfell that's where he can find Jon
or Tyrion or even Brienne and let them
know that he has left Cersei and joined
their cause I believe in the first
episode we are also going to see
wonderful preparing its defences photos
already came out online that showed
Winterfell ready for war and we already
saw them making armor in season seven
and once the dragonglass gets there
thousands of weapons will be made also
they will have guards watching the
entire perimeter of the Winterfell
property that's at least until Jon and
all the other forces arrive and devise
their plan of attack it's going to be
interesting when Winterfell calls all of
their banners because this is when we
could see some old characters come back
into play ed mere Tully is still out
there somewhere
and Howland Reed is still out there
somewhere - in that little [ __ ] Robin
Arryn is still alive speaking of loose
ends you're a Greyjoy still needs
rescued as well and I'm pretty sure that
we're gonna see at least one great joy
in the first episode if not all of them
the only problem is I can't say exactly
where you're a Greyjoy is at this point
she may be chained up on your own ship
the silence or he may have her detained
at the Iron Islands while he's out
gallivanting around the world picking up
the golden company so in my opinion I
think there is only two ways Theon is
going to be able to set her free
if Yara is on your own ship Theon's
gonna need to save her before Euron gets
the golden company
or else there's no way Thielen and his
small crew is going to be able to get
her back off of his ship when he's
surrounded by his own Ironborn men and
20,000 mercenaries I think the easiest
way for Theon to get her back would be
for her to be locked up at the Iron
Islands while urine is getting the
golden company
this would allow Theon to do a very
similar rescue mission as Yara tried to
do for him
Theon could show up in the middle of the
night in hope that only a skeleton crew
is guarding Yara and if Theon and his
men could breach the Iron Islands and
get her back this would set up for a
bigger confrontation between Theon and
Euron later into the season if your ax
what happened to be at the Iron Islands
then we could see fiona arriving there
or at least seeing the Iron Islands in
the distance
in the first episode then the scene
could cut the yer on arriving in Essos
and we could finally get a good glimpse
of the golden company preparing to come
to Westeros finally but let's just say
Yara is still on board the silence with
Joran if that's the case then I don't
think feelin's gonna try and save her in
the first episode because I think that's
too early for the Theon and you're on
face off just yet unless he was able to
sneak onboard and get her off without
being spotted but that seems very
unlikely at this point but since I
mentioned esos I think there is also a
very high chance we could see Melisandre
and Orkin vara in the first episode also
Melisandre did tell Varys she was going
to volantis but she said she would
return considering season 8 is the final
season she is gonna have to show up in
one of these six remaining episodes so I
won't be surprised if we get as seen in
volantis at the beginning of the season
Melisandre will need to put her final
plan into action and considering what
she said to Varys before she left
it seems she may have something up her
sleeves since she believes she will die
when she comes back to Westeros she may
rally the fiery hand while she is in
volantis and when they learned the great
war is here we could see a true war of
vice versus fire by soldiers versus fire
soldiers but who knows but before our
ramble too long let me tell you what I
think the last scene will be in the
first episode I do have a feeling they
will win the premiere episode with
something pretty big I think the episode
will end with either John arriving in
Winterfell in seeing Aria and Branigan
for the first time since season 1 or the
first episode will end with the night
king making his first contact was
something south of the wall
I am pretty confident the night King
will strike the last hearth or karhold
first and this would be a great way to
end the first episode by showing one of
the northern castles getting obliterated
by the night king in his army it's not
gonna be an all-out war in the first
episode it's just gonna be a taste of
what's to come and it would put the
north on high alert the night King is
already adding more meat to his army and
he's heading your way next but they may
also want to end the premiere on a
softer note by having John finally
reunite with his family before all hell
breaks loose I do have very high
expectations for the John and REO
reunion but that John and bran reunion
is gonna send shockwaves across the
Seven Kingdoms everything that John
thought he knew was a lie and I can't
wait to see the look on his face when he
finds out he was never a bastard but
instead he was the true heir to the Iron
Throne but I am also dying to see how
the Narus reacts to this news also and I
can't wait to see how everyone in the
North reacts to Daenerys showing up with
John and her dragons
it's going to be awesome intense and
awkward and emotional when everything
else under the Sun but this is just a
basic outline of what I think will
happen in the first episode I'm sure I'm
gonna get a few things wrong but I am
pretty sure we will touch base with all
of the main storylines just to kind of
set the stage for the final season I
wasn't really sure what order I should
put any of these scenes in because
that's very hard to guess but this
should give you a good idea of what I
think will happen during the premiere I
will probably changed my mind about some
of these things over the next few months
once I have some more time to think
about it but for now this is a good
place to start let me know what you
think about my list and feel free to let
me know some of the things that you
think is gonna happen in this series
premiere thank you all for watching a
video I really do appreciate that and I
also want to thank all of my patreon
supporters I can't thank you all enough
for your generosity I hope you all have
a great day I'll see you in the next one
bye
you
[Music]